open up your Bible read 23 for me so
people this is now the third time I've
answered the question which is good the
more we answer something repetitively
then it becomes second nature by the
power of the Holy Spirit okay so now go
to John 2023 read and then ask your
question and let me charge my phone as
you're doing that what does it say so
read John 203 John 20 and 23 says if you
forgive the sins of any they are
forgiven them if you withhold
forgiveness from any it is withheld
so I know some would use that as well
you know we have the power to forgive
sins like God Almighty yeah well
remember what I said I told the
Catholics Orthodox Coptic Orthodox and
the Church of the East what passages
won't work and what will work sorry one
second I'm just
coming now when I used
to oppos
Catholicism more
rigorously this was not a p you would
quote to try to prove confession to a
priest because contextually I could show
you that's not the meaning but I will
give you a passage
that establishes the principle of
confessing your sins to the body of
Believers which then you can extrapolate
from that that since the church is
headed by Bishops Elders appointed by
the Holy Spirit how much more do you
need to confess to them okay but John
2023 is not a passage to supported it's
not I'm letting you know if you guys
want to convince Protestant
Protestants of the validity validity of
confessing to priests or Bishops don't
go to John 2023 because I'm going to
explain to you contextually what our
Lord is talking about we don't start at
23 let's start at 21 read 21 to
23 Jesus said to them again peace be
with you as the father has sent me even
so I am sending you and when he had said
this he breathed on them and said to
them receive the Holy Spirit okay now
before you move on the context is Jesus
sending them out and the
regenerative power and life of the Holy
Spirit to preach the gospel
right right it's in that context he says
read even though I hear uh your dishes
in the background keep reading man stop
at 22 if he forgive the sins of any they
are forgiven them if you withhold
forgiveness from any it is withheld okay
in the context everyone in the
context Jesus is speaking of sending the
disciples out into the world as he was
sent out by the father why was he sent
out by the father to preach the message
of Salvation through through faith in
him and condemnation if you reject him
that's the context and then he breathes
unto them the Holy Spirit to regenerate
them with spiritual life and then
Empower them on the day of Pentecost to
go forth and Carry Out The Great
Commission it's in that context that
Jesus says whoever sins you have
forgiven shall be forgiven whoever sins
you retain shall have been retained
meaning through your proclamation of the
Gospel you'll have the authority to say
someone your sins are forgiven
or to say to someone you stand condemned
why on the basis of their response to
the Gospel of Jesus Christ for example
read John 2030-31
now Jesus did many other signs in the
presence of the disciples which are not
written in his book but these are
written so that you may believe that
Jesus is the Christ the son of God and
that by believing you may have life in
his name see he just proclaimed
forgiveness you are forgiven When You
Believe in the name of the son of God
you will receive eternal life have life
in you when you believe in the Son of
God you don't believe in the Son of God
you remain in your sin you'll be
condemned to Hell John 3:16
to8 let me
get that's that's the meaning of this
passage but I'm gonna give you another
passage that does
establish the validity of confessing
your sins to qualifi spiritual leaders
appointed to oversee the flock of Jesus
Christ I'll give you that and many of
you already mentioned it you already
mentioned it it's James 5:14 to6 but
it's not John 2023 at least not for a
Protestant you won't convince them okay
now read John 3:16
to18 for God so loved the world that he
gave his only son that whoever believes
in him should not perish but have
eternal life for God did not send his
son into the world to condemn the world
but in order that the world might be
saved through him whoever believes in
him is not condemned but whoever does
not believe is condemned already because
he has not believed in the name of the
only son of God so you see how John is
forgiving sins and retaining sins by
saying you believe in the name of the
only begotten Son of God you won't be
condemned you won't perish you'll have
eternal life you do not believe in the
name of the son of the only begotten Son
of God you are condemned and you will
perish right okay that's that's the
context of John
20:23 but let me give you a passage that
establishes the validity of
acknowledging your sins to other
believers in the body of Jesus Christ
which you then extrapolate from that
acknowledging your sins to a qualified
spiritual leader who oversees the body
of Christ now I need everyone to
listen what passages do you guys quote
to show the validity of confessing your
sins to a priest or a bishop are you
ready everyone in the chat are you
listening are you ready let's pray we
get 400 before the session's over I want
to make sure they're listening not
debating okay everyone knew James 514
to6 we go to James 5:14 to6 but I'm
going to give you some other verses to
tie in with James 5:14
to16 it's not just James 5:14 to6
other verses to tie in with James 5:14
and
16 goad read
it okay James
54-6 is anyone among you sick let him
call for the Elders of the church and
let them pray over Elders of the
church leaders of the church you call
them they pray over you and anoint you
with the oil of God's people in the name
of the Lord and that oil would be olive
oil so and then what happens keep
reading
and the prayer of faith will save the
one who is
sick and the Lord will raise him up and
if he has committed sins he will be
forgiven therefore confess your sins to
one another there you go and confess
your sins to one another as the members
of the body of Jesus Christ and then
keep
going and pray for one another that you
may be healed the prayer of a righteous
person has a great power as it is
working yeah but it says confess to one
another not to the priest or the Elder
well by implication if Elders are
mentioned and you are to summon them to
pray over you and anoint you with oil to
heal you but your sickness is the result
of sin what do you think you're going to
do if not confess your sin to those
Elders
right right but now let me give you
Hebrews 13:17
de and Prince they'll tell you that's
the Old Testament we don't have an
office of priesthood in the New
Testament because it is the priesthood
of Believers because I know what the
Protestants going to say to that ducen
they're going to say there is no office
of priesthood in the New Testament
because it's the priesthood of Believers
I know because I I used to use these
arguments to refute this assertion now
everyone's a priest so you don't go and
confess to a priest who then offers an
animal sacrifice in the
temple Hebrews
13:17 all right it says obey your
leaders and submit to them for they are
keeping watch over your souls so if the
leader keeps watch over your
soul and you need to obey your
leader and don't make it hard for him
because God has appointed it to watch
over you to teach you to guard you to
protect you to feed you rebuke you and
correct you if NE
necessary as a tool of the Holy Spirit
then you take James
54-6 confess your sins to one another
with this passage you have a leader who
is called to watch over you to whom you
must give an account and submit to how
much more must you confess to
him all right re finish Hebrews 13:17
brother yes sir um it says that keeping
watch over your souls as those who will
have to give an account let them do this
with joy and not reg growning for that
would be of no advantage to you you
catching it now don't keep going don't
go beyond seven did you catch it now
what it says verse seven there are
leaders appointed to watch over your
soul and they're going to have to give
an answer to the Lord for your life
entrusted to their care as your Shepherd
right right all right now you're warn
don't make it harder for them then it
already is don't make it a burden for
them to watch over you because it's not
going to Bod well for you when you stand
before the Lord so now let's take these
two passages connect the dots one
passage says confess your sins to one
another in the context of calling Elders
to pray over the sick who may be sick
because of unrepentant sin and the
elders will pray and anoint the person
with oil they'll be healed so if we are
to confess our sins to one another
especially sins that are have resulted
in discipline in our life how much more
should you be confessing your s sin to
that Elder that leader that Bishop whom
God has called to watch over your soul
and whom you're are accountable
to all right that's the
principle makes sense and then if you
look at the diday it's going to get
worse because the diday when I say it
gets worse for the Protestant the diday
talks about when you gather together on
the Lord's day to celebrate the
sacrifice make confession of your sins
that's in the dedicate a document
written in the lifetime of the Apostles